Guten morgen tim.
Rebellion gegen das aussterben quatsch bin bei der revolte gegen das aussterben.
Spalter.
Aux
Logbuch netz politik nummer dreihundert und fünfzehn die revolutionäre ausgabe von logbuch netz politik wir schreiten voran.
Ja wir nachdem wir uns der feinde entledigt haben ja die es gibt nur ein die wir noch mehr hassen als die regierung als die römer das ist die.
Die rebellion gegen das aussterben.
Ihre kinder sterben.
Ich dachte wir sind die leute gegen das.
Nein das ist die populäre front die sitzt da drüben.
Oh mann ist das wieder schön zu schön zu beobachten also oder auch nicht es kommt immer darauf an wie viel innere ruhe man gerade durch den eigenen anstrich der tapete,
ins ins ins ins gemüt bekommt ja mann mann mann mann mann also man wenn man.
Ja ja.
Heute ist der siebter siebter oktober.
Gerade demonstriert oder rebelliert.
Es wird rebelliert von den falschen der feind ja der feind kämpfe unsere ziele.
Ne die richtigen machen's aber falsch.
Also die.
Nicht in der farbtöne die wir gerne hätten.
Wir haben nichts gegen rebellen aber diese rebellen sind dagegen.
Ihr tragt die falsch.
Diese rebellen sind auf unserer seite ja das ist das schlimmste was du machen kannst wie sagte ein kumpel von mir,
es gibt nichts schlimmeres als für einen wert konservativen linken als eine neue gruppierung die die eigene deutungshoheit angreift ich bin auch schon ganz beunruhigt.
Ja was ist geschehen also klimawandel ist das große thema.
Endlich übrigens auch kommen wir aber gleich noch zu beim kongress wird das auch wieder eine rolle spielen aber klimawandel ist das thema was uns gerade beschäftigt wir erinnern uns die bundesregierung hat ein klima paket beschlossen dass,
klingt nicht nur wie ein teil aus aus der auf preisliste von vw sondern das wirkt auf jeden fall von preisliste von vw nämlich irgendwie nicht wirklich,
gegen den klimawandel in dem kontext gab es,
klima streik der ja von friday for future,
auf zudem von aufgerufen wurde wo sich sehr viele gruppierungen dann beteiligt haben wir hier auch in berlin und in vielen anderen städten
im deutschsprachigen raum stattgefunden hat und auch international in australien und in weiß ich in wie vielen ländern beim klima streik sich beteiligt wurde.
Heute findet in deutschland die finden die aktion statt,
von zu den extension rebellion aufruft und vielleicht kurz erklären das ist eine gruppierung die ihren ursprung in dem vereinigten,
königreich hat die,
wo sich überlegt wurde nun wir haben denn in der vergangenheit gesellschaftliche gruppierungen tatsächlich.
'ne radikalen wandel herbeigeführt radikaler wandel im sinne von des,
plötzlich krasse änderung in der politik waren ja also dass sowas wie ein apart hals regime zum fall gebracht oder die endlich die die großen gesellschaftlichen veränderungen.
Und da haben sie eben geschaut okay,
offensichtlich das was da sehr erfolgreich ist in solchen bereichen ist der zivilen ungehorsam denn wir haben ja festgestellt mit reden aufklären und fordern
haben wir es die letzten jahrzehnte versucht in diesem bereich und das ergebnis,
können wir ja jetzt sehen deswegen setzen wir nun,
kalkuliert auf mittel des zivilen ungehorsam was ist wieder ungehorsam nun eine,
öffentlich angekündigte regelverletzung die gewaltfrei ist,
aber disruptive das klassische beispiel sitz blockaden als eine das ist eine regelverletzung den straßenverkehr zu zu unterbrechen es ist eine.
Oder den bahnverkehr wie bei den protesten in go erleben.
Im leben oder eine demonstration an ihre durchführung zu hindern sind alles regelverletzung.
Die allerdings nur bedingte einschränkungen,
anderer mit sich führen insbesondere die also gewaltfrei sind oder ne wie rosa parks im
teil des busses sitzen wo sie nicht sitzen soll ja wo man sagen kann ja einzigartig hier noch gegen spricht ist wirklich die regel aber sonst gibt's hier keinen anhaltspunkt warum du nicht
hier sitzen solltest wenn der hier der platz besser gefällt als der andere,
und dadurch kann man natürlich wenigstens für großen großen gruppen macht kann man damit eben ein druck aufbauen der politisch eben wirkt ne wenn du jetzt irgendwie versuchst als einzelperson einen.
Sagen wir mal ein straßen verkehrsknoten lahm zu legen wird der,
gefährlich schwierig hast du relativ große repressionen erwartungen zu
hegen wenn du aber das jetzt mit vielen hunderten oder vielen tausend menschen macht sind es irgendwann auch einfach zu viele um die noch sinnvoll daran zu hindern oder bestrafen zu können,
das ist.
Kann man da nur noch den status quo verwalten und das ist eigentlich das ziel der ganzen.
Das ist das ziel der ganzen sache und mit diesen mitteln die immer und immer wieder diskutiert werden müssen also hat,
es gab jetzt auch schon beim klima streik wurden ja teilweise kreuzungen
blockiert oder auch die sehr beliebte und sehr schöne aktions von der critical mars wo also mit fahrrädern in einem großen verbund gefahren wird und der verbund hat jetzt
rechtlich die position,
eben zusammen zu bleiben also straßenverkehrsordnung gibt das her dass du ab so und so viele fahrzeuge verkehrsteilnehmerinnen erkennbar in einem verbund fährst,
und das bedeutet dann wenn du jetzt über eine kreuzung fährst dass du die und die kreuzungsbereich phase wo du grün hast
ist kürzer als dein verbund braucht um die kreuzung zu überqueren dass du den dass du trotzdem in den verbund weiter fährst diese regel ist er hat natürlich nicht,
gerechnet dass es hier in berlin regelmäßig gelingen würde verbunden von mehreren kilometern länger in radfahrern zu schaffen die ebene dreiviertelstunde brauchen bis sie durch die kreuzung durch sind das entsprechende konsequenzen eben
für den straßenverkehr also hier eine disruption des straßenverkehrs niemand kommt wirklich zu schaden.
Und dadurch eben eine deswegen also der zivile ungehorsam übrigens,
das letzte mal bei der critical mars war eine sehr schöne situation wo einer der autofahrer die da blockiert wurden,
länger warten mussten an einer kreuzung laut rumschreien ist jetzt zum termin,
ja das waren bestatter sorry wenn's ein gewerbe gibt wenn das wirklich nicht dringend zum termin muss ne dann ist es der stadt.
Würde ich jetzt so nicht unterschreiben ja.
Ja ne aber es gibt echt so viele leute die einen davon überzeugen können sie müssen jetzt dringend zum termin aber bestatter da ist jetzt da kommt jetzt nicht mehr darauf an,
gut also extension rebellion ist enorm schnell gewachsen ist eine junge gruppierung die mit dieser idee quasi einen,
radikaler drin in anführungszeichen flügel den friday it's for future zur seite zu stellen in fünfzig ländern aktiv mehr als dreihundert ortsgruppen dreißig davon allein in deutschland hat also in sehr kurzer zeit,
sehr beachtliche zuwachs zahlen gehabt und geht das ganze eben sehr,
mit einem mit einem framework an das ja so relativ klar sagen so okay was sind die methoden die sich in der vergangenheit als erfolgreich gezeigt haben also wieder ungehorsam machen wir nicht weil wir zivilen ungehorsam gut finden sondern.
Wahrscheinlich auch aber primär weil er sich in der vergangenheit für die großen gesellschaftlichen änderungen als das
wirksamen mittel gezeigt hat gewalttätigkeit nicht deswegen gewaltfrei ausgrenzung irgendwelche andere aufgrund anderer,
oder nicht für das thema relevanter faktoren hat die bewegung geschwächt deswegen machen wir das nicht das hat jetzt dazu geführt dass die einerseits zu radikal für die bürgerlichen sind
ja also demonstrieren schon aber bitte bitte nicht auf den rasen treten dabei na also das das geht ja wohl nicht und gleichzeitig
sind sie den einmal radikaler den linker rennen bewegungen nicht radikal,
wo die extension wo es eine beim
klima streik eine sitz blockade gab und sitz blockade heißt eben man setzt man bleibt da sitzen bis die polizei einweg trägt man
auch das gesetz blockade klassisch gewaltfrei setzt sich dahin in der gruppe da muss die polizei dich eben weg tragen wenn sich weg,
hilfst du nicht dabei steckst aber jetzt auch nicht um dich und schießt ja die polizei tut dir dann weh mit schmerz griffen und so aber du bist eben friedlich und gewaltfrei.
Also,
da gab's also eine sitz blockade die eben ne wir bleiben hier sitzen bis die polizei und,
trägt und da kam dann leute von extension rebellion setzen sich dazu dann wurde aber aus der,
aus der sitz blockade irgendwie polizisten beschimpft oder gesänge irgendwie die zum inhalt hatten dass die polizei nicht gut wäre,
und leute wieder gegangen was ein bisschen zeit wir bleiben hier sitzen bis die polizei und zweck trick es sei denn jemand sagt was gegen die polizei dann gehen wir freiwillig,
wie das eben passiert wenn du eine neue gruppierung hast die,
auf tradierten bewegungen stößt die sagen wir singen unsere lieder das haben wir schon immer so gemacht und alle brüllen sind eben,
so und so ja was dann das haben diese das brauchen die sonst fühlen sie sich nicht wohl und.
Das vor allem für die polizei hat eine sehr schöne methode dann irgendwie das auch schneller aufgelöst.
Genau das ist es tradition das ist braucht ja die polizei zu provozieren damit sie dann auch
fester auf die fresse haut und dann kann man wieder sagen du hast das ist so braucht das ist ähnlich wie bei dir im stadion tim wenn du deine da werden auch immer die gleichen lieder gesungen und der gegner ist ein arsch ne
so und jetzt kommen sie nee nee.
Läuft bei uns ganz anders.
So genau bei uns.
Bei uns im stall.
Wenn der gegner nicht mehr werden werden hier wer hier die stimmung viel besser.
Okay und in in großbritannien hat diese extension rebellion im relativ großen erfolg.
Da setzt jetzt natürlich auch das ein was man repression nennt,
auch wieder so ein begriff repression die repression aber im prinzip nicht dass das zurück drücken,
der staatlichen stellen die im sanktionen müssen hier eben eine,
ordnung aufrechterhalten diese ordnung wird bedroht durch methoden des zivilen ungehorsam also haben jetzt in großbritannien hat die polizei london nachdem tausende demonstranten brücken kreuzung irgendwelche plätze besetzt hatten und damit,
eben in london stark druck gemacht haben haben sie mehr als tausend menschen in gewahrsam genommen und eine liste,
mit den demonstranten veröffentlicht die mutmaßlich gegen gesetze verstoßen hätten samt geburtsdatum und wohnort in großbritannien ist er fragt man sich wirklich in auf welcher
ebene die da so agieren das völlig völlig irrsinnige aktion auch wieder in deutschland läuft es natürlich anders.
Hier wird jetzt,
extension rebellion gerade eben sowohl von dem bürgerlichen lager,
als auch von dem sag mal etwas radikal linken lager massiv angegriffen,
weil diese ja junge bewegung sich eben wie alle anderen auch den ein oder anderen,
fehltritte mal leistet ja also irgendwie 'ne ungünstig ist oder eine reaktion also du kannst halt nicht erst in der sitz blockade aufrufen dich da hinsetzen und dann gehen ne das sind.
Das ist blöd für die die sich auch dahin gesetzt haben weil ihr kleiner die sitz plakate ist desto größer ist das risiko dass die leute da sind noch sitzen auf die nase bekommen das geht eben nicht ne es waren auch andererseits leute die es vielleicht zum ersten mal gemacht haben
das erinnert mich auch ich weiß nicht ob ich das mal erzählt beim acht gipfel in heiligendamm,
zweitausendsieben gabs auch eine wunderschöne situation da habe ich auch.
Ja konnte ich ein bisschen lächeln deshalb nicht nicht nicht besonders weit von dem gelände in heiligendamm weg wo eben einer der ich glaub das waren drei hauptsache zugang straßen dieser blockiert wenn einer an einer davon war das.
Und jetzt saßen da quasi diese diese block diese blockade saß jetzt nicht unweit des zaunes der dieses gesamte heiligendamm gelände eingezäunt hatte
die polizei ging aber jetzt nicht besonders dagegen vor weil es glaube ich noch über einen dritten weg gab es noch zugang zum gelände oder so das war irgendwie waren relativ friedliche situation,
und jetzt saß da also diese sitz blockade und jetzt für die polizei mit dem wasserwerfer vor,
ja wasserwerfer ist ein relativ großes fahrzeug hat hinten großen tank drauf und oben eine wasser pistole.
So wurde das den,
offenbar sehr jung und unerfahrene demonstrantinnen auch geschildert und sie haben dieses fahrzeug auch erkannt dass sie das fahrzeug erkannt haben und daran gesehen dass sie anfing sich aus müll säcken ja,
müllsack genommen rechts und links ein loch und in der mitte ein loch regenjacken zu bauen und müllsäcke,
über zu ziehen saß denn da rein in ihrer sitz plakate und dann legen sie so diese maler folie über ihre beine ja,
jetzt ist das so dass sie wahrscheinlich noch nicht so ein wasserwerfer im einsatz gesehen haben weil diese folie und dieser müllsack jetzt nicht nicht
nichts nennenswertes schutz gegen gegen ein solchen wasserwerfer der halt weiß nicht mit zwanzig war oder was sie also der kann man ja auch regeln die haben.
Da geht 's weniger um die nässe als vielmehr um den druck.
Genau der wasserwerfer ist nicht da damit er nicht nass machen das es geht eher darum dass der mit einem so hohen druck arbeitet dass der dich wirklich halt weg,
drückt,
ist ein wasser drücker und ja das hatten wir noch kurz leid aber es war dann auch sehr schön dass selbst der polizist der dem wasserwerfer.
Merkt ihr halt dass sie gerade mit messer zur schießerei gekommen sind und liest dann nadel falten und soweit ich das jetzt noch in erinnerung habe ist der dann auch nicht zum einsatz gekommen,
es gibt also auch bei neuen bewegungen eben ein paar sachen die die die an erfahrung vielleicht brauchen,
oder noch sammeln müssen und paar sachen an diese naiv drangehen so zum beispiel den fragebogen von extension rebellion.
Zwar haben die einen fragebogen online gestellt indem sich die leute für diesen.
Generalstreik oder für diesen aufstand gegen das aussterben der eben heute jetzt hier.
Anmelden konnten und da hatten sie einen einen haben sie eine eine ganze reihe fragen die dort gestellt wurden.
Heute man sieht also anwenden mit name,
und e-mail adresse und da kam sofort dürfen wir die hier abgefragt und daten mit deinen kontaktdaten verknüpfen ja nein hast du bereits an einem aktionstag training mitgemacht ja nein bei welchen,
aktions form hast du schon mitgemacht blockaden lok ins klo und performances also anklicken was du alles schon so offen holz hast ne und.
Bist du bist du bereit ins gefängnis zu gehen bist du bereit.
Teilzunehmen bist du bereit ich in gewahrsam dem zu lassen voraussichtlich für wenige stunden irgendwie so.
Wo landen eigentlich diese daten wer hatte denn und warum wollt ihr das wissen konnte man auch vernetzung mit anderen gruppierungen angeben so ja ich bin,
bei was weiß ich ende gelände aktiv und ich habe mich schon mal ich habe mich schon mal irgendwo festgeklebt und,
ich bin bereit ins gefängnis zu gehen mit einer wollten so eine richtig geile potenzielle datenbank der radikalen.
So eine rebellion tinder.
Jungs.
Oh super du passt aber auch echt wunderbar zu uns.
Und das war das war jetzt nicht nicht besonders klug und da haben sie natürlich auch.
Ja hinweise bekommen dass das keine besonders gute idee ist aber schön ist natürlich,
auf welche weise dann solche solche hinweise kommen ne dann wird irgendwie,
da sofort recherchiert aha da kommt aus england da sind ja bekannte aktivistinnen dabei und jetzt sagen sie mir nicht kennt die was sie da tun wir versuchen uns hier zu integrieren die sind vom verfassungsschutz
wird ja alles das es kommt ja alles dazu inklusive dass dann jutta dietfurt kennst du noch jutta dietfurt.
Na ja klar aus den achtzigern aus den frühen grünen tagen eine sehr wort gewaltige meinungs gewaltige person die dann aber irgendwann unter protest die grünen verlassen hat weil sie mit keinem mehr klar kam und immer so als die totale hardcore,
linke verschrieben war nicht ganz so unrecht je nachdem wie man dazu steht es mag das ja auch okay sein,
auf jeden fall immer sehr streitbar und mischt sich auch seitdem immer mal wieder gerne ein oder wird durch die medien eingemischt ich weiß nicht so ganz genau wieder der prozess läuft ob ob jeder sich da denkst du das ist doch mal was da fragen wir mal die jutta immer wieder ja doch da mal wieder einen guten kommentar.
Herr,
also eine jutta dietfurt zwanzig neu gründung eine serien gründerin oder sowas von einer gruppierung zur nächsten.
So viele.
Ja jetzt ist sie dort dann irgendwie liste sowieso die liste muss dann auch fünf mal gespalten und umbenannt werden öko links ich glaube jetzt irgendwie in frankfurt im stadtrat oder so ne und geht den leuten da auf den geist,
ist auf jeden fall sage ich mal,
früher oder später wenn man sich mit gesellschaftlichen änderungen prozessen auseinandersetzten gerät man an jutta dietfurt und muss sich von jutta depot beschimpfen lassen weil das eben die wirksamkeit von jutta food ist allen zu erklären wie scheiße sie sind
um damit sie eben,
gehört findet deswegen wandte sich dein jutta dietfurt gestern mit einem ausführlichen wahn aufruf vor extension rebellion an die öffentlichkeit und da muss ich halt irgendwie fragen,
ganz ernsthaft leute dass ihr den.
Man kann ja eine ganze reihe kritik vielleicht haben.
Aber es gibt auch eine ganze reihe an möglichkeiten diese kritik solidarisch vorzutragen,
man kann sich an die leute wenden und sagen hör mal das mit dem fragebogen was ihr da macht das ist vielleicht nicht so eine gute idee nimm den mal runter lösch mal die daten wenn ihr hilfe braucht kann man euch erklären wie das geht,
warum ist das problematisch,
können wir euch auch erklären oder man kann irgendwie vor letztendlich die eigenen leute zu größeren feinden erklären als den gegner und das ist irgendwie etwas was in diesem gesellschaftlichen gruppierungen,
zumindest in den progressiven am laufenden band stattfindet.
Dass die linke krankheit.
Und das schöne ist quasi mit dem auf.
Mit dem das etablieren von extension rebellion in deutschland wurde von einem buch begleitet das buch heißt wann wenn nicht wir,
glaub ich ja,
wann wenn nicht wir genau und ist im fischer verlag erschienen ich hab wurde gebeten von der herausgeberin ob ich denn nicht auch ein kapitel beitragen möchte.
Genau dieses kapitel habe ich dann auch veröffentlicht und ich habe.
Dann mir überlegt so nachdem ich mir das konzept von berlin da so habe erklären lassen wir so gedacht naja was wäre denn so deren probleme sein und habe dann ein kapitel darüber geschrieben welche,
mit welchen problemen eine solche gruppierung eben rechnen muss und finde es ganz spannend weil,
da ich hab da so über spaltung geschrieben und was das bedeutet wenn man
nach allen seiten offen ist und keine zentrale kontrolle struktur hat das nämlich eine reihe an an bekloppten aktion stattfinden werden von einzelnen die dann die ganze gruppierung in misskredit bringen sollen und es.
Grüße an die piraten partei an dieser stelle.
Genau und es läuft halt gerade alles so voll nach nach buch ne also voll nach
nach prophezeiung und so wie es immer gelaufen ist und es ist auch wirklich so vorhersehbar dass dann eben solche leute wie jutta dietfurt oder so dann auch genau so diese,
differenz profiteure ja die dann irgendwie versuchen müssen wenn irgendwo eine möglichkeit
wenn die spaltung ist sehr interessant ja und jetzt gibt's also die die haupt kritiker von extension belgien sind helge braun
kanzleramt.
Minister heißt es ist die rolle glaube ich der hat und da da da sind sie also wieder vereint,
den wahren feind und das ist das ist so bedauerlich eigentlich wie,
wie.
Wie sozusagen jede rebellion im keim erstickt wird weil man sich erstmal überhaupt formalien streitet so anstatt einfach anzuerkennen dass,
in meiner extension berlin wird unter umständen auch nur also
beides möglich kann sein dass wir noch in zehn jahren darüber reden was das doch für einen blühender moment war damals zwanzig neunzehn als es losging und guck mal was ihr alles erreicht haben,
aber auch sein dass wir uns gerade so eben noch daran erinnern dass es das überhaupt gab,
lukas wichtig ist es dass,
zu diesem zeitpunkt überhaupt aktion stattfinden weil es geht ja hier um das thema und das thema denk ich mal ist weitgehend unumstritten zumindest in unseren kreisen oder sollte es zumindest sein dass wir es halt einfach mal was tun müssen weil einfach die zeit.
Teilweise schon abgelaufen ist ja aber auf jeden fall auch noch weiter abläuft was die unmittelbaren konsequenzen daraus betrifft und.
Es sicherlich ganz sinnvoll ist sich auch zumindest soweit zu positionieren dass man nicht in gefahr gerät mit irgendwie so voll horn.
Frei.
Spinnen irgendwie verwechselt zu werden die einfach den schuss nicht nur nicht gehört haben soll halt auch sich instrumentalisieren lassen von,
von extrem zweifelhaften kräften und diese argumentation luft,
für ein weiter so die muss einfach dünner werden und solche solche aktionen egal wie man sie jetzt im einzelnen bewertet,
nehmen einfach da den sauerstoff raus.
Und da kann man und du kannst ja natürlich.
Also du kannst ja vieles von dem was bestimmte gruppierungen machen nicht in ordnung finden,
meine güte ist jetzt auch kein geheimnis das ist im netz politischen bereich 'ne ganze reihe an akteuren gibt,
wo ich jetzt nicht.
Sagen würde da wäre ich bereit mein meine zeit oder mein geld irgendwie zu investieren.
Die volksfront für datenschutz.
Die.
Volksfreund bedeutet schutz das sind spalter.
Ja das ist.
Ein,
es gibt nur ein den wir mehr hassen als googeln dass die volksfront für datenschutz wir sind die datenschützer deutsche front so ne das also totaler unsinn und es wäre es ist
niemand gewinnt wenn wenn wenn solche gruppierungen versuchen sich irgendwie gegenseitig irgendwie,
platz wegzunehmen oder sich einbilden um irgendwelche ressourcen zu kämpfen ja das ist also wirklich,
ganz ganz trauriges niveau und ganz unterste schublade und diese ohne diese solidarität,
und manchmal kann die solidarität auch,
einfach darin bestehen mich ganz ehrlich zu sagen die zähne zusammen zu kneifen und zu knirschen ja und zu sagen so boah alter was ihr da macht das halte ich jetzt vielleicht gar nicht für hilfreich aber.
Ich werde jetzt nicht hochgehen und auch noch sagen dass ihr idioten seid weil ihr steht halt auf unserer seite ihr seid zwei idioten aber ihr seid unsere idioten,
so und das muss man ja eben auch mal,
würdigen.
Ja klar und ich meine es gibt natürlich immer unterschiede darin wie wie man jetzt auch die nächsten schritte und die eigentlichen forderung so.
Einschätzt und und und zu bewerten hat und was was da das richtige ist oder so ja also extension rebellen
sagt halt so ja handelt jetzt sagt die wahrheit und das sind so die ersten beiden forderungen da geht ja jeder noch mit so und dann kommen sie halt mit ja wir brauchen aber jetzt bürgerinnen versammlung
fang natürlich dann gleich wieder ein paar anzuschreiben sagen oh nee es ist aber demokratisch zweifelhaft des ding und die,
und überhaupt und was damals irgendwie in der französischen revolution richtig war das muss ja heute nicht so das ist einfach die falsche debatte so und und und.
Könnte dann führen wenn die eu in der nähe ihres zieles wären.
Ja ist ja nicht so dass sie sich erst erst auf eine straße setzen oder am nächsten tag wird der bundestag geräumt ja also das
einfach sind schon noch so ein paar schritte dazwischen und die kann man dann auch erstmal abwarten und das dann irgendwie später bewerten.
Ich würde genau also wenn ihr wenn ihr irgendwann in die nähe einer bürgerinnen versammlung kommen dann können wir darüber diskutiert finde es besonders also ich finde das auch echt elegant ja du kannst dir irgendwie als
als regierung echt sicher sein dass er sitze oh interessant da ist jetzt echt eine gruppierung die macht hier die legt irgendwie die stadt,
klar das kann das kann nach einer ganzen menge ärger,
aussehen die sind relativ gut organisiert die könnten uns jetzt hier nochmal richtig feuer machen weil wenn ich hier jede woche jede eine woche lang die stadt lahmlegen denn wer könnte jedes thema setzen was sie möchten so ne und,
dann kann 's nicht aber es als als regierung,
kannst du dir eigentlich gewiss sein dass du einfach nur da hingehen muss und sagst du ja aber wie ihr seht wie steht ihr denn bitteschön zum konflikt zwischen israel und palästina,
so und dann kannst du sicher sein dass sie noch vorabend rot,
vom platz sind weil die sich in fünf lager spalten und über die israel palästina flage frage streiten die in ihrer jetzigen situation vor vollkommen
irrelevant ist aber zu der sie auf jeden fall eine meinung haben die sie nicht bereit sind zu diskutieren deswegen machen sie das auch den ganzen tag.
Und während ihr euch dann alle sozusagen über solche details streitet ja und und und und euch sozusagen mit vollkommen neben nebensächlich den dingen beschäftigt ihr euch von der eigentlichen protest form ablenken.
Kommt da die cdu und lädt ein neues banner in ihr twitter profil hoch oder entsteht es gibt kleine keinen planet b wir handeln für mehr nachhaltigkeit,
for future landen cdu for future.
Wirklich dein ernst.
Doch das ist das habe ich eben das ist wahr.
Du willst doch auch da sitzen die sitzt noch da und lachen sich die kommen noch vor lachen nicht in den schlaf.
Genau schreibt schreibt doch cdu vor future der ist gut das machen wir.
Laden jutta dietfurt ein.
Genau über angemessene protest form im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert.
Oh mann ey ja aber also das ja anschluss fähigkeit ist ein großes thema und.
Ich gucke mal was,
ach die spd hat ja ist ja nicht rechtzeitig auf twitter gekommen um sich dandy.
I will mira hat irgendwie seit einem jahr nichts mehr geschrieben.
Die spd gar nichts mehr gemacht.
Tja wo war das.
Oh schön.
Es fdp ist auch schon weg also es spd de und da ist halt irgendwie.
Leute.
Gemeinsam lernen.
Irgendwelche leute die alle spd logo falsch rum halten eine der ja das ist es ist sehr schmerzhaft.
Oh je aber das schöne ist das eigentlich.
Also alles was über progressive bewegungen im kern,
zu sagen ist tatsächlich in wenigen sketches von mon tv.
Wiedergegeben ist ne.
Die jetzt fünfzig jahre alt sind.
Die fünfzig jahre alt sind.
Und die zukunft sehr gut vorhergesagt.
Volkswagen von was hat er was haben die römer hier für uns getan das ist alles.
Ja man man kann sich eigentlich relativ schnell politisch auf den stand bringen man schaut sich einfach mal,
dreimal hintereinander das licht an und dann weiß man welcher santa allemal folgen sollte.
Unser unser film.
Ja ja das ist in der tat.
Tja.
Es gibt aber noch andere gründe warum.
Es gibt andere probleme ja.
Andere gründe warum wir keine schöne dinge.
Die usa.
Usa.
Die und die haben also jetzt das sache die wir hier auch schon verlieren angekündigt haben das also facebook beabsichtigt nun.
Seine messenger,
dienste zu vereinheitlichen sie haben im prinzip wenn ich das richtig sehe drei primäre messenger das ist whatsapp den sie sich ja gekauft haben dann in instagram gibt es.
Die möglichkeit sich direkt messages zu schicken und dann gibt's noch den facebook,
messenger und jetzt möchten sie das gerne diese alle drei irgendwie vereinheitlichen bisher haben sie nur,
bei whatsapp eine ende zu ende verschlüsselung reingesetzt das war eine ihre reaktion auf die noten enthüllungen.
Wo ich ja immer noch sehr.
Interessiert bin ob ob das letztendlich heißt dass es genug daten über die menschen haben das in die metadaten reichen oder ob sie.
Das machen mussten als weil sie irgendwie so ausreichend großen vertrauensverlust durch die snow enthüllung hatten dass jetzt mal irgendwie ein.
Mal was in den ring werfen mussten ein ein ein sehr krasses zeichen des guten willens.
Jetzt haben sie angekündigt schon vor einiger zeit sie möchten dieses schutz niveau der signal fotografie.
Auch auf die anderen messenger ausweiten und sie wollen die glaube ich auch in der operativen machen das jetzt irgendwie von dem instagram-account an whatsapp schreiben kannst oder die irgendwie,
gemischt werden oder so was sie da genau vorhaben weiß ich nicht aber auf jeden fall krypton auch bei facebook messenger und instagram dirk messages spaß hintergrund ist übrigens das diese fotografie,
dieses protokoll was bei der verschluss was hier eingesetzt wird das hat maximal ins bike entwickelt,
früher bei twitter auch in der it-sicherheit war ursprünglich beabsichtigt diese ende zu ende verschlüsselungsmethoden in die twitter derek messages zu bringen,
das hat er da nicht durch gekriegt daraufhin hat er dann dabei,
bei twitter ausgestiegen hat irgendwie red phone dann gemacht und das ging irgendwann über in.
Signal und die krypton graf ie des das protokoll dieses wie also dort ende zu ende verschlüsselung ausgehandelt wird und umgesetzt wird das hat dann wurde eben zu einem ja,
exportschlager in dem sinne dass das protokoll jetzt auch an anderen stellen anwendungen.
Twitter führt solche diskussionen glaube ich bis heute nicht und facebook tut ja,
jetzt gibt es einen offenen brief von mehreren regierungen der five eis gegen die sich natürlich diese verschlüsselung primär richtet.
Die jetzt also sagen ja ihr müsst aber natürlich aufpassen,
das könnte das wird ja ganz fürchterliche folgen haben unter anderem meldet sich hier der general william zu wort und der,
der director die dann also sagen ja aber damit werdet ihr jetzt zur plattform für für ja sagt man das.
Charlie pornographie also für,
für kinder vergewaltiger und das wird alles wird alles ganz fürchterlich und ihr führt zu finden damit zu problemen.
Für die für die strafverfolgung die verlangen also natürlich jetzt einen zugang zu dieser ende zu ende verschlüsselung.
Eine diskussion die auch nie endet.
Nö ich meine es.
Sagen die ende zu ende diskussion wird nie enden.
Ja das ist äh.
Auch nachvollziehbar weil wir ja wie werden wir auch später noch haben natürlich mit dem mit meinen auch immer das andere kommt ne und das sind einfach sich wieder,
die diskussion muss halt auch weiterhin geführt werden.
Wenn wir sehen wie das also das das wäre also sollte facebook das tun wir das zum wiederholten mal die größte.
Das größte ausrollen von ende zu ende verschlüsselung das erste größte ausrollen von ende zu ende verschlüsselung war whatsapp mit eben den weiß nicht ob das wie viele milliarden nutzer whatsapp zu dem zeitpunkt hatte.
War glaube ich noch im millionen aber hunderte millionen bereich.
Hunderte millionen bereich ich weiß ich weiß dass der dieser neunzehn milliarden kaufpreis damals in dollar pro nutzerinnen übersetzt wurde sagen wir mal die hätten eine milliarde nutzer.
Zu dem zeitpunkt gehabt wie dem auch sei.
Eigentlich bemerkenswerte war der preis pro laufenden pc- für diesen dienst das war auf jeden fall eine der geilsten investment.
Das waren relativ wenige ne weil es irgendwie indem wir nutzen erlangen ne das zwischen ja da geht.
Ja ja vier.
Schöne vier computer.
Milliarden.
Ja die kosten vier komma vier komma sieben fünf milliarden pro stück habe ich das richtig gerechnet wahrscheinlich und diese.
Wenn sie das jetzt bei facebook und instagram machen dann ist das natürlich auch eine der größten,
eines der größten ausrollen von ende zu ende verschlüsselung die da passieren kann gleichzeitig sollten nun,
hier regelung geschaffen werden die den zugriff darauf,
wiederum zulassen dann wäre das eines der größten einer der größten angriffe auf,
private kommunikation dies hier gegeben hat es wird also recht spannend interessant ist dass mark zuckerberg hier tatsächlich sehr,
mit offenem visier fast kämpft er sagt ja wie es durchaus,
klar dass das für die polizei,
zu einer einschränkung führen wird wenn wir das tun er vergleicht das glaube ich so mit kämpfen mit einer hand auf den rücken festgebunden.
Sagt aber dass er glaubt dass die privatsphäre der eben milliarden nutzerinnen die davon betroffen ist hier überwiegt und das höre gut ist und die dass sie eben sagen
die melde wir werden sehr viel mehr auf die melde funktion unserer nutzerinnen setzen,
die also dann inhalte melden können zu quasi
anzeigen können an interne systeme oder auch an die polizei und das sehr,
sehr interessant also finde ich.
Heißt das versuchen system wie ist zwar alles verschlüsselt aber wenn einer aus der gruppe beschließt da äh zum bissel blauer zu werden dann,
diese fotografie aufgehoben sozusagen.
Das also ich vermute das so ihr melde system funktioniert dass das daneben dass das hier diese naht hier in dieser nachricht wurde ich bedroht oder so
dann kannst du ja eh die verschlüsselt also die ist ja dann und verschlüsselt bei dir ja und die vertraulichkeit also man könnte auch argumentieren dass das ja okay ist weil die vertraulich,
kalt der nachricht an dich ist jetzt technisch sichergestellt was du damit machst ist eine andere sache das ist ja dann musst du als empfänger.
Sagen ok ich so die wurde mir vertraut,
bedrohen lassen muss oder dass ich mir hier illegales material zu senden lassen muss nur weil es verschlüsselt wurde ne also ist ja dann eine ein anderes layer auf dem diese diskussion.
Stattfindet.
Na ich denke facebook hat mittlerweile auch gemerkt dass sie halt mit einer mit einer positionierung die nicht.
Sich hinter die nutzer stellt langfristig nicht viel erfolg haben werden,
weil zum beispiel apple das ja nun genau andersrum machen und dementsprechend davon auch profitiert hat in dieser ganzen debatten.
Es ist interessanterweise also ich mein immer wenn es um verschlüsselung geht es außer zehn jahren gleich.
Oder wahrscheinlich seit seit es um verschlüsselung seines verschlüsselung gibt gleich ist das internet gibt terror und,
kinderpornografie das sind die beiden themen die da immer kommen und jetzt muss man sein dass es so sicher wie das amen in der kirche wird einfach kein anderes thema angebracht werden.
Nazi schatz ja werden wir mal ganz schön.
Ja das interessiert aber keinen ja ja aber das ist ja nicht ne ich sage nur welche themen kommen.
Ja ja ja ja genau die organisierte kriminalität.
So und jetzt ist es tatsächlich so dass facebook.
Zwanzig achtzehn siebzehn millionen fälle möglichen kindesmissbrauch gemeldet hat.
Und geschätzt wird das von den siebzehn millionen gemeldeten fällen schätzungsweise rund zwölf millionen,
dann nicht mehr bemerkbar gewesen wären denn facebook hat so scheint es hier eben,
automatisierte aktions filter auch auf den privaten nachrichten und die würden damit eben wegfallen.
Also die haben es ja relativ klar ist ja auch bekannt haben wir auch öfter darüber gesprochen dass es eben.
Wenn jetzt ein bild von einer solchen plattform gebannt wird letztendlich etwas gibt wie uploadfilter.
Die also diese bilder erkennen flaggen können und wenn ihr jetzt auf die idee,
kommen solltet einen legalisiert den inhalt oder ein illegalen inhalt lieber facebook zu senden dann ist das.
Erstens sowieso eine besonders doofe idee zweitens wird facebook das eben
erkennen können diese filter können sogar noch besser sein dass ihr vielleicht mit künstlicher intelligenz und sonstigen arbeiten das fällt weg wenn sie eben hier eine ende zu ende verschlüsselung.
Einbauen und mich hat diese zahl siebzehn millionen fälle die facebook tatsächlich meldet dann doch.
Muss ich sagen also das ist erscheint mir also erscheint mir höher als ich erwartet hätte jetzt ist natürlich ein fall ist nicht immer eine person.
Sondern ein fall ist eine datei,
wir können also eine relativ wenige personen können sich unter umständen sehr viele dateien zugesendet haben und nicht jede siebzehn millionen fälle sind siebzehn millionen unterschiedliche dateien sondern es ist natürlich immer die frage wie ist ein fall definiert.
Aber das ist schon,
ein nennenswertes phänomen mit dem ich in dem ausmaß gar nicht gerechnet.
Hat aber übrigens auch zur folge dass wenn die kita etwas entdeckt dann wird 's nachher geprüft von menschen,
und diese kit erkennt primär halt leicht begleitete kinder was wiederum etwas ist was auch im familiären kontext sich sehr viel,
hin und her gesendet wird im sommer wenn das kind in windeln zum ersten mal mit dem die ersten schritte auf der wiese macht und mit dem rasensprenger kämpft oder sowas ne dann.
Oder ohne windel.
Oder das wollen wir natürlich das dürfen wir nicht ne,
in den usa kannst du sowas sowieso nicht machen aber genau also da gibt's natürlich auch eine reihe an.
Ja verdachts momenten die sich vielleicht eben aus durch andere kontexte erklären lassen.
Aber wir haben jetzt hier mal diese debatte eben auf einer ebene die nicht mehr wie sonst wo wenn wir über verschlüsselung reden
wo also gesagt wird hier es gibt diese terroristen wir müssen das darknet verbieten und wir müssen in diese in diese verschlüsselten messenger rein sondern jetzt ist es wirklich mal auf der ebene wo es alle betrifft nämlich willst du deine facebook nachrichten sollen verschlüsselt sein oder nicht.
Und argumente dagegen ist kinderpornografie und,
willst so da da da ist diese gesellschaftliche debatte jetzt mal auf einer ebene wo sie wirklich alle betreffen wird das heißt da wird sie wahrscheinlich jetzt auch entschieden,
auf einer ebene wo.
Sie eine mal alle betroffen hat insofern könnte das.
Die debatte aller debatten werden wenn sich das weiter zuspitzen.
Ja schauen wir mal.
Hongkong da ist ja auch die ein oder andere rebellion am laufen das geht schon lange,
vielen monaten mittlerweile ne das sind diese proteste in hongkong da am start das ganze ist,
ausgelöst worden oder sagen wir mal nochmal so eine eskalation modus gebracht worden durch,
eine ankündigung eines neuen gesetzes was eben die auslieferung von bürgern aus hongkong an mailand china ermöglicht hätte.
Und dann ist es halt alles total eskaliert und es ist immer noch dabei total zu eskalieren mittlerweile ist man so weit dass die das auch schon protest.
Was gesagt leute die hier demonstrieren von polizeikräften erschossen geschossen werden also das ist sehr gestorben jetzt gerade.
Nein der ist der wurde geschossen in die schulter ich hatte auch das video davon gesehen hast,
sag mal die die schilderung dass hier jetzt von der polizei auf demonstrierenden geschossen wird.
Wird dem jetzt nicht so unbedingt gerecht wäre es jetzt irgendwie nicht.
Relativieren aber der war schon sehr klar in einer in einem angriff der polizist war sehr klar in einer verteidigungspolitik jon.
Ganz unabhängig davon.
Und wurde mit einer stange geschlagen so dann hat sich dieser schuss gelöst.
Der polizist wurde mit der stange wie auch immer das ganze eskaliert das das.
In eine richtig krasse gewalt diese formulierung inzwischen schießt die polizei sogar schon auf die demonstranten,
ist damit vorsicht anzubringen.
Dann hab ich das.
Richtig richtig übel vielleicht auch nicht das nicht um nur das schießen sondern weil ich mal die schießen seit monaten mit tränengas granaten die ganze zeit auf diese leute ist eine sehr krasse gewalt die dort stattfindet,
und diese gipfel eben jetzt auch in in schusswaffen gebraucht ja.
Wie das eben so ist und die leute entwickeln natürlich,
ihre verteidigung strategien insbesondere was diese tränengas tränen gas geraten betrifft sie ja auch,
da interessante strategien entwickelt wie sie die schnell einsammeln und unschädlich machen können gibt's ja lustige videos dazu sicherlich das eine oder andere anschauen kann stellt sich raus auch noch chemie muss man nur,
beherrschen ich kann's gar nicht erklären hast du kennst du diese methode.
In essig oder so.
Würde jetzt nur unseren reden deswegen lasse ich das lieber egal darum geht's jetzt auch erstmal gar nicht sondern es geht um digitale antworten unter anderem gibt es nämlich eine online map wo,
straßensperren und das vorgehen von polizei durch die crowd verzeichnet wird,
live und da kann man sich halt,
online darüber informieren wo jetzt gerade bedrohung szenarien,
entstehen aus welchen gründen auch immer unter anderem weil du halt verhindern willst das mit deinen kindern irgendwo der straße lang läuft wo halt gerade mit drin gas durch die gegend geworfen wird.
Praktischerweise packt man sowas ja dann auch schnell mal in eine app rein die meistens nicht sehr viel mehr ist als so 'n rapper um so eine webseite herum das ist glaube ich hier auch der fall,
ja und,
wo es dann natürlich diese app in einem appstore stellen weil so funktioniert,
ist auch so also sowohl im google store als auch im app store gab es diese app oder gibt es diese app.
Im apple app store in hongkong appstore wurde dann aber der zugriff auf diese,
und die entwickler kriegt eine mail von apple wo drin stand ja eure.
Könnte er dazu benutzt werden um von benutzer dass sie sozusagen um vermeiden könnten.
Und das würde ja gegen die app store prinzipien verstoßen und dementsprechend würde jetzt diese app aus dem store genommen werden dann gab es natürlich entsprechende proteste,
ein zwei tage später wurde denn diese entscheidung wieder rückgängig.
Die das ganze in deutschland übrigens auch ne von.
Hat man glaube ich auch mal drüber.
Haben wir glaube ich darüber gesprochen ja.
Ja es ist jetzt an dieser stelle unklar natürlich dann gleich die passenden verschwörungstheorien,
inwiefern jetzt hier die entscheidungsgewalt gelaufen ist aus meiner perspektive würde ich sagen.
Hat jemand eine entscheidung gefällt im team.
Also es gibt ja diese review leute die halt für apple apps überprüfen entweder bei neu einreichung bei updates oder,
aus anderen motivation heraus was weiß ich dass jemand.
Irgendwas hingewiesen hat dass man sich doch besser nochmal anschauen soll.
Und bis zu einem bestimmten grad haben dann eben diese review auch die möglichkeit eben die regeln zu entworfen,
und da gehört unter garantie auch die entscheidung dazu mit die app sperma jetzt mal ob das dann,
im first level passiert oder ob es da noch eine zweite person geben musste das dann ab segnet keine ahnung weiß ich nicht wie es funktioniert aber es ist auch nicht so dass es jemals jedes mal eine vorstandssitzung scheidung patino ist,
dafür ist es einfach alles.
Ja dann gibt's halt diese protest sein wird das eben öffentlich gemacht dann führt sowas sicherlich auch öfter mal dazu dass ich dass man sich solche entscheidungen nochmal anschaut ist besonders in so einem kritischen bereich wo es dann hier gleich,
mit viel schreinerei und onlineartikel verbunden ist und dann wird's manchmal eben auch wieder zurückgenommen hier ist das erfolg.
Ich weiß nicht was man jetzt hier dazu sagen kann dann kommt natürlich dann sofort wieder die debatte hoch mit ja das hat man jetzt davon mit zentralisiertes app stores und weiter gehts hin so sehr viel leichter angesetzt werden ja stimmt klar natürlich ist so und.
Im falle von apple kann man natürlich auch sagen.
Wenn es jetzt so gewesen wäre was man nicht weiß was ich aber ehrlich gesagt ich glaube in dem moment das jetzt hier die regierung angekommen wäre und gesagt hätte hör mal.
Ihr verstoß hier mal aber richtig kolossale gegen unsere gesetze wenn ihr das nicht mal ganz schnell ändert dann entziehen wir euch,
lange liste von privilegien oder lange liste von grundrechten ja,
sowas kann passieren sicherlich in china auch nicht anhört auf.
Ähm ich glaube allerdings dass sich hier mehr umso voraus einen gehorsam handelt was natürlich auch probleme.
Andererseits wenn man keinen zentralisiertes appstore hat und solche entscheidungsgewalt ferien dann hast du das problem wiederum das eben,
zerstörerische content und da kann man sich auch eine menge einfallen lassen wiederum eben nicht so ohne weiteres rausgenommen werden kann.
Apple steht ja auch mal regelmäßig in der kritik entweder weil sie irgendwas gesperrt haben von dem alle leute der meinung sind das sollte nicht gesperrt werden und dann am nächsten tag auch wieder genau andersrum warum später denn das nicht so also wie man es macht.
Mein stand ist dass es diese app jetzt wieder gibt.
Ja kann ich trinke hat aber nur eins komma sieben sterne haben wahrscheinlich eine ganze menge chinesen runter gevotet.
Ja oder leute wir waren der meinung dass sie jetzt apple irgendwie damit irgendwas aussah.
Ja das kommt ja auch regelmäßig vor dass leute die app die app runter worden um apple zu beschimpfen.
Aber es gibt auch es gibt sechs readings.
Eine reihe ein stern und eine,
fünf stern rating also fünf einstimmen einverständnis,
andererseits will man vielleicht auch als person nicht unbedingt diese app,
bewerten im app store weil das ja auch immer öffentliche profile sind diese eins ab damit verfolgen wir in meiner bezug s gruppe mit folgenden fünf personen.
Ja der hat überhaupt nicht funktioniert wir wollten da irgendwie die fensterscheiben eingeschlagen da stand da überall bullen rum die waren überhaupt nicht eingetragen.
Und einer hat auf mich geschossen ein stern.
Scheiße ne aber keine erfahrung hat mir so wollte.
Ja also.
Es zeigt einfach wie schwer wieder solche solche diskussionen sind zum glück sind solche solche applikation ja auch immer schön auch als webseiten abbild bar ich glaube das haben wir auch gemacht dann.
Das ist im wesentlichen eine website die dann halt gewebt ist da ist jetzt an dieser app glaube ich nicht sehr viel tolles.
Und deswegen war der schaden auch nicht ganz so oder war der schaden vernachlässigbar weil die leute nehmen so auf die seite zugegangen sind aber es zeigt einfach diese also diese konflikte zeigen immer.
Wie blöd sowas eben schief geht ne natürlich das ein problem dieser zentralen platz.
Aber deswegen haben.
Solange wir noch browser auf unserem handys haben dürfen ja.
Das internet bleibt ja auch ein problem,
deswegen waren das jetzt wieder auch fragst jetzt war das zwanzig neunzehn warnt das b,
es gäbe nämlich eine hohe bedrohungslage im bereich der politischen akteure,
so so und deswegen hat das b parteien und ihren abgeordneten dringend dazu geraten ihre server und internen netzwerke abzusichern zu schreibt der spiegel,
und sie sollten.
Ein monitoring zur angriffs erkennung einrichten und ihre it so aufstellen das sensible bereiche entkoppelt und so besser,
von vor hackern geschützt sein und da frage ich mich ernsthaft also.
Ich meine erstens sind das ja auch wieder so so so nicht ratschläge sichert eure server und intern netzwerke ab,
man am ende werden abgeordnete gehackt und nicht netze,
ich frag mich ernsthaft in welcher it-sicherheit welt die leute,
leben die immer noch so so etwas reden ja wir haben es ist ja nun mal gerade,
ich darf daran erinnern ziemlich genau.
Neun monate her dass wir mit diesen orbit boxing angriffen auf eine reihe,
von politikerinnen und personen des öffentlichen lebens veröffentlichungen hat
ja also erstens so wir raten euch dringend dazu jetzt eure server abzusichern wenn man euch ernsthaft heute noch dazu raten muss eure server abzusichern dann seid ihr sowieso längst von oben bis unten durch gesäubert
da brauchst du jetzt nicht mehr irgendwie dennoch gedanken über deine internen netzwerke zu machen als wenn diese advent politische
abgeordnete mit internen netzwerken agieren würden die haben eine e-mail-adresse entweder account und ein telefon und damit regeln die da ihr geschäft und die schicken sich irgendwie ihre komischen
gesetzesentwurfes die ganze zeit per e-mail durch die gegend,
machen das an ihre privataccount weise in diesem bundestag salty irgendwie am wochenende nicht an ihre e-mails kommen so ungefähr,
ja das ist alles so,
also ich weiß nicht genau was ich was ich schlimmer finde dass das irgendwie zwanzig neunzehn überhaupt noch solchen rat von sich gibt oder dass das wahrscheinlich zwanzig neunzehn einen solchen rad immer noch von sich geben muss
beides lässt mich hoffen deswegen haben wir jetzt eine geheimwaffe.
Hast du christian lindner schon in seinem cyber kostüm gesehen.
Ja ich muss gleich wieder wegklicken weil es war schlimm.
Ich musste erstmal mir bin irgendwie browser ohne adblocker benutzen weil.
Geheimwaffe lindner geheimwaffe lindner zieht in den cyber krieg und ich würde sagen nichts illustriert besser.
Nichts illustriert besser des deutschland absolut nicht in der lage ist einen cyber krieg zu führen,
und dass wir sehr sehr sehr gut beraten werden hier,
eine defensive strategie zu gehen weil wenn wir schon den lindner schicken müssen.
Dann ist das da können wir die den kumpel dann sollten wir ihm wirklich auch direkt so eine weiße fahne in die hand geben ja weil das das also
der ist irgendwie leutnant der reserve oder so muss jetzt dazu
zur übung und natürlich politiker muss natürlich dann hier signale betreiben und ist dann da,
hat sich dann da irgendein spinner von der bildzeitung noch dazu geholt um sich in dem schlecht sitzenden kostüm da fotografieren zu lassen.
Das ist wirklich das ist wirklich zeigt die nichts anderes wie absolut hilflos deutschland da sein wird deswegen brauchen wir eine
defensive strategie sagt der c seit jeher das sagen die gutachten des wissenschaftlichen dienstes des bundestags selbst der lot e v der
den liberalen nahe netz politik verein hat er jetzt kürzlich ein positionspapier zugeschrieben wurde das auch nochmal für ja für,
für wirtschaftsliberale erklärt hat und alle die sich damit auskennt sagen das.
Und dass die bundeswehr sich nicht damit auskennt die einzige die es nicht sagen dass illustriert eben auch hier der lindner und deswegen finde ich das besonders schön.
Und hoffe denke dass der christian lindner hier der bundesrepublik deutschland ein gefallen getan hat um hier zu zeigen dass wir,
in einer vollkommen falschen strategie werden wenn wir offensiv in diesem internet versuchen würden uns zu positionieren.
Demnächst wenn ich ins.
Etwas hinzuzufügen ist der debatte rund um libra,
ähm berichtete werden das hier mal technisch vorgestellt und ein wenig diskutiert libra ist ein,
kryptowährungen projekt was von facebook aus.
Technisch entwickelt worden ist,
im juni wurde das vorgestellt und mit dieser vorstellung kam nicht nur die technik,
beschreibung sondern es gab dann eben auch gleich ankündigung dass man jetzt eine libra assoziation in der schweiz gegründet hätte,
und siehe da man würde das auch nicht alleine machen sondern man hätte ja auch diverse partner mit dem boot und abgesehen von so ein paar,
die sich noch mit dazu gemalt haben.
Waren auch interessante player aus der finanzindustrie,
mit an bord unter anderem auch paypal.
Und nun wiederum hat aber paypal,
libra assoziation wieder auszusteigen dem projekt schon irgendwie noch verbunden bleiben möchte aber so jetzt erstmal nicht in aller erster reihe damit weiter kämpfen.
Was hat es damit.
Warum.
Ähm also vielleicht nochmal kurz zum verständnis was was hinter libra so steckt libra ist eine kryptowährung die zwar mit blockchain technologie,
arbeitet aber das sozusagen nur unter den teilnehmern innerhalb dieses projektes sprich in dem moment wo man diese,
währung scharf schaltet würde quasi so eine blockchain verwendet werden unter den teilnehmern,
die alle quasi in ihren systemen in ihren welten mit libra währung handeln können also leute das verkaufen können oder leuten die erlaubnis geben und die gelegenheit geben in liberalen.
Dinge zu bezahlen und geld entsprechend entgegenzunehmen und in dem moment wo man aber
diese libra aus dem eigenen system herausbringt geht man dann eben durch diese libra blockchain damit hast du nicht so eine weltweit verteilte blockchain die gegenüber allen permanent abgesichert werden muss das ganze ist
sehr viel weniger aufwendig und nur in so einem kleinen kreis.
Technisch ist das alles ganz interessant das haben wir ja auch gesagt dass man damit sehr wohl eine,
private währung realisieren könnte nun hat sich aber seit dieser bekanntgabe bei den staaten.
Ein erheblicher widerstand gebildet.
Ach was ja die nehme ich so alle so wie was ihr wollt jetzt hier eine eigene währung machen und nicht mehr unsere benutzen und so offensichtlich haben sie denn schon verstanden dass mit
the power auf facebook das ganze auf einmal eine dimension bekommt um die man sich kümmern muss und es wetter da halt einfach aus allen,
seiten und man wurde auch schon kreativ olaf scholz hat sich mittlerweile dann für einen euro ausgesprochen jetzt will man also.
Nein euro da können wir mit dem euro unsere egos bezahlt wird alles toll mit i euro.
Sag jetzt erstmal nichts dazu ist.
Das gibt's doch schon heißt nicht iron irgendwie diese.
Das schreibt sich ein bisschen anders.
Ja aber eure.
Also ist ja auch egal also es ist ja sicherlich jetzt erstmal ich werd jetzt nicht anfangen und der bundesregierung vorwerfen dass sie sich jetzt,
über digitale konzepte gedanken macht ja es ist völlig in ordnung so sollen sie gerne mal tun wird ja auch mal zeit.
Wir brauchen ein ein scholz.
Aber klar ist auf jeden fall der widerstand das war jetzt auch nicht nur in deutschland als auf europäischer ebene in usa überall gab es einfach erheblichen widerstand,
und die haben alle gesagt so leute könnt ihr könnt ihr vergessen,
ich weiß noch als wir darüber gesprochen haben hatte ich glaube ich erwähnt und sie wollen ja dann quasi die absicherung also bitcoin ist ja ein kryptowährung system was quasi nur komplett auf sich selber steht das heißt dieser,
wert der sich derzeit aus bitcoin kaufen und verkaufen ergibt ist ja quasi ihre eigene spekulationen blase,
bei libra wollte man halt einen relativ stabilen,
verbund haben mit dem weltwährung system dementsprechend wäre dann eben quasi sehr wert auch selber durch entsprechende währungsfonds nach hinten abgesichert,
mit us-dollar mit ein paar anderen währungen noch mit dazu und weil ihr die frage wie das dann eben so richtig aufgestellt ist so oder so ist auch klar dass bei so einem modell,
die staaten
auch mitspracherecht haben und das machen sie jetzt eben auch gültig aber eben nicht so im sinne von macht mal wir schauen mal was bei rauskommt sein ne ne wir haben ja jetzt erstmal angst vor und lass das mal besser bleiben also es ist noch nicht wirklich was für,
verboten worden aber die zeichen waren jetzt relativ stark und es ist wohl offenbar auch druck ausgeübt worden.
Auf entsprechende player die schon etabliert sind sprich eben solche unternehmen wie,
paypal die jetzt schon die ersten konsequenzen gezogen haben und wenn man eine gerüchte küche glauben darf ist auch bei visa und bei mastercard und bei strip,
auch ein eine entsprechende zurückhaltung generiert worden ob sich das demnächst auch dein kind.
Äußern wird dass sie dann auch sich offiziell aus diesem projekt verabschieden und no aber sieht auf jeden fall erstmal gerade nicht so gut aus.
Apple ist übrigens auch jüngst gefragt worden wie sieht denn das so sehen und ob sie jetzt nicht auch vorhaben jetzt muss ich schon mit apple pay und apple card unterwegs sind auch noch eine eigene kryptowährung auf dem markt zu bringen.
Da haben sie sich allerdings ganz klar,
dagegen ausgesprochen sie wollen das nicht tun sie wollen im klassischen bildungssystem bleiben und da ist player mitspielen aber sie haben keinerlei pläne in irgendeiner form kultur zu machen und halten das auch für falsch.
Ich halte da ich weiß nicht ob es falsch oder richtig sehe halt nicht warum
das was das jemand tun warum das jemand tun sollte.
Na kommt drauf an welche interessen du hast also ich meine wenn du,
was sie der der mittelmeer sein möchtest für alle finanziellen transaktionen was ja im prinzip das business modell schlechthin ist ja also.
Aber dann brauchst du halt keine blockchain aber das habe ich damals auch schon gesagt.
Da gab's übrigens einen klugen kommentar da gab es einen kleinen kommentar den wir hier mal nicht zu der letzten sondern zu der vorletzten sendung,
der sagte also waren etwas länger des um das zu lernen sagte was die meinen sind blockchain technologie und er meint damit das daten also blockchain nutzt verschlüsselung,
also ist verschlüsselung blockchain-technologie.
Das ist so der der name ja.
Und die speichern daten also ist speichern blockchain-technologie.
Alles ist jetzt blockchain-technologie.
Signatur also signatur ist natürlich viel eher das ding was da zur anwendung kommt also nicht nicht verschlüsselung sondern sondern signatur also ist daten integrität zu checken und signieren blockchain technologie.
Ähnlich wie der touchscreen der ja jetzt in autos teilweise verbaut wird kfz technologie ist.
Also unsere unsere gesamten handys haben ja k f z technologie das kennen wir ja aus dem auto.
So so wird er halt argumentiert.
Das sofa das sofa ist automobilindustrie auf die blase zwei autos haben auch sitze.
Ja gut aber in dem fall in dem fall bei libra ist es wirklich blockchain-technologie und zwar genau die die eigentlich ursprünglich damit gemeint war und.
Ich hatte ja schon gesagt das macht auch total sinn so wie sie das verwendet haben.
Verwenden wollen die haben es ja noch nicht verwendet.
Ja richtig also.
Zumindest wird es offenbar schwierig dass in europa zum einsatz zu bringen und vielleicht auch in den usa das könnte natürlich das projekt insgesamt ein wenig in gefährdung bring ich
kann man aber sehr wohl vorstellen dass diverse ergibt wo sich das trotzdem noch reingemogelt und dann versucht so ein bisschen durch die hintertür zu etablieren also dass das thema ist sicherlich noch nicht
komplett durch aber der widerstand steigt und so schnell wird's auf jeden fall erstmal nicht.
Schon wieder am schluss der sendung.
Schon wieder das ist doch super.
Ja aber wir haben ja auch noch ein paar tage gehabt und wollten jetzt mal weil sich in dieser woche kein anderer termin finden lässt datum gesagt.
Doch haben wir fünfter oktober.
Siebter oktober.
Doch werden's erwähnt in dem.
Im zusammenhang mit der rebellion mit der volksfront.
Mit der rebellion volksfreund von wer könnte ich mich stundenlang darüber wie diese leute irgendwie immer in die eigenen reihen schießen in meine eigenen reihen.
Das ist das ist das problem.
Daran erkennst du idioten da finde ich echt super das also es gibt keinen besseren marker für idioten als dass sie irgendwie ihre eigenen ihre eigenen leute oder sagen wir mal
eben nicht ihre eigenen leute aber die die anderen gruppen auf der gleichen seite angreifen die was die wollen die welt retten das wollte ich machen.
Ja aber das ist das ist aber ein problem der linken die
rechten die haben ja auch idioten aber die machen das anders sie sagen wer ist denn jetzt hier gerade der größe führer
und dann laufen dem alle hinter hinterher dass so sehr führer ist vollkommen egal wie das heißt ja ob das jetzt die,
cana sind weil die dsgvo weil die afd hauptsache oder die npd hauptsache es jetzt einfach gerade der lauteste schreit und wenn wenn morgen die afd nicht mehr da ist und dann wird irgendeinen anderen
es ist ja auch in österreich.
Aber die konzentrieren sich auf die in greifbarer nähe stehenden politischen ziele,
ja die verwickeln sich jetzt nicht in diskussionen darüber wie sie,
die judenfrage klären sondern die sehen erstmal zu wie sie,
wie sie jetzt die migrationsfrage klären ja die gehen halt gezielt und nacheinander vor und sagen nicht so ne also,
entschuldigung mit dieser positionierung zum israel palästina konflikt können wir keinen nationalen widerstand in einer einheitsfront leisten so das machen die einfach nicht.
Nee soweit denken die.
Aber das geile ist diese ganzen stuhl kreis linken ja die denn da sitzen und sich irgendwie gucken wie sie das was sie jetzt schon gespalten haben mit denen sie sitzen nochmal spalten können die sagen die nazis sind doof.
Finde ich auch immer sehr schön.
Ja man muss muss ich halt auch über die farbtöne der plakate gedanken machen nicht dass sich irgendjemand davon verletzt fühlt schon.
Komm lass uns hier.
Wir sind alles,
und es gibt es gibt kein richtiges leben im universal falschen ja genau und weil das so ist brauchst du hier auch nicht mehr zu diskutieren du voll pflege ja schön ja die haben alles die haben alles nicht verstanden ah schön.
Gut dass wir so schön unsere intelligent sind linos.
Doof nur ich bin schlau.
Ja und ich ich.
Aux